innanzitutto grazie per attenzione che
ci metterete dopo questa giornata densa
di contenuti
quando ted bologna ci ha invitato a
partecipare a questo evento
io e tutte le mie persone che lavoriamo
insieme ci è piaciuto molto poter
riflettere sul concetto di innovazione
perché forse oggi è un'urgenza
provare a riflettere come rinnovare
l'innovazione fare in modo che
l'innovazione sia utile ma soprattutto
che sia più attuale e contemporanea al
nostro modo di vivere di lavorare
partiamo da un presupposto
stamattina tutti gli interventi
mi hanno dimostrato e confermato che
l'innovazione
esponenziale l'innovazione delle
tecnologie è un dato di fatto
l'innovazione stanno accelerando il
cambiamento in ogni processo che noi
viviamo il modo in cui progettiamo il
modo in cui produciamo il modo in cui
regolava mo organizzavamo le nostre
imprese sta cambiando il modo di
recuperare capitale il modo di gestire
la relazione con i clienti una relazione
sempre più asimmetrica dove il potere si
sposta sui clienti il modo in cui
compriamo siamo solo al fatto che
l'acquisto oggi è un equilibrio fluido
tra digitale analogico ma fra qualche
tempo non parliamo più di digitale
analogico parleremo di un'unica realtà
quindi ci troviamo in un contesto dove
non parliamo più di competizione a
parliamo di per competizione non
parliamo più di informazione ma parliamo
di iper informazione un contesto dove
tutti ci raccontano che è un mondo dove
i confini si confondono un mondo
complesso e la complessità si definisce
rispetto a noi come persone
prima l'innovazione era appannaggio di
poche in poche aziende il potente
ricerca oggi anche le ultimo evento
scorsa volta a roma sui maker oggi ci
dimostrano come l'innovazione
con la caduta delle barriere appannaggio
di una moltitudine quindi se parliamo di
evoluzione anzi rivoluzion non è quindi
di noi come persone che vivono una
trasformazione sarà ancora più
esponenziale
pensate a la nostra generazione che
utilizza le tecnologie per fare cose
vecchie in modo nuovo ma i miei figli
faranno cose nuove in modo nuovo e
allora avremo servizi diversi prodotti
diversi guideremo macchine senza
guidatori avremo robot quindi
l'innovazione di fatto porterà a vivere
nella trasformazione
in modo diverso
quindi cosa è cambiato il mondo e sempre
cambiato e solo che è più veloce il
cambiamento
allora vi faccio una domanda ma
nell'equazione dell'innovazione
esponenziale che ruolo hanno le persone
sono limite o sono risorsa
preparando questo intervento mi sono
divertita andare su wikipedia
13 mila voci che parlano di innovazioni
scusate su google wikipedia descrive
l'innovazione come uno dei migliori modi
che ho trovato molto semplice
l'innovazione quell'atto che cerca di
migliorare la vita alle persone e alla
società allora parliamo di progresso se
no se non la migliore se non la cambia
in modo positivo parliamo di regresso
però io sono un'imprenditrice
ma sono ancora design e il fine ultimo
dell'innovazione è di migliorare le
nostre vite
ma
che cosa succede come facciamo noi no a
fare in modo che se l'innovazione abbia
fine raggiunga il cambiamento positivo
come facciamo a portare a bordo le
persone oggi non basta essere un
processo di trasformazione per
partecipare al cambiamento
lo dobbiamo comprendere lo dobbiamo
partecipare
non dobbiamo subire l'innovazione lo
dobbiamo agire e quindi come facciamo ad
aiutare noi come persone a uscire dai
nostri schemi dalle nostre fissità
mentali dai nostri paradigmi dalle
nostre convenzioni per non rimanere ai
bordi
perché questa appena vuol dire che se
noi non adottiamo capiamo e non
partecipiamo rimarremo ai bordi
quindi siete d'accordo con me che oggi è
in noi noi come persone vedremo le come
imprese noi come collettività che il
luogo di massima innovazione
accelerazione esponenziale e su di noi
che dobbiamo fare questa trasformazione
quanti di voi quest'anno hanno dovuto
ripensare nuovi mestieri completare le
proprie competenze mettere in crisi il
proprio progetto di vita
rinnovare il proprio modo di lavorare di
essere
quindi vuol dire che noi noi come
persone ognuno di noi è un impresa e
all'interno di imprese
ma e quindi se noi vogliamo come imprese
ridisegnare i nostri modelli di servizio
di business nuovi prodotti cambiare il
modello di relazione
accelerare l'innovazione non possiamo
farlo senza le nostre persone e se noi
come imprese non ci riusciremo
non riusciremo neanche a fare quello che
dice wikipedia di migliorare la nostra
vita come collettività e come società
allora la domanda è
come accelerare questo processo
perché sono convinta anche se voi fate
mente locale a quello che quando
lavorate tutti i giorni andate in un bar
andato in un ristorante parlate con i
vostri clienti
vi rendete conto di come molti non
comprendono quello che sta succedendo
e quindi come possiamo aiutare
a essere partecipi come accelerare
questo processo ma accelerare il futuro
come ci chiedete di bologna di
riflettere a questo noi abbiamo un
progetto che ha una passione che un
movimento una filosofia come la volete
chiamare è un credo che alla uil cono
micela capace un enzima la wake o nomi
l'enzima voi sapete è un catalizzatore è
un forzato re di connessioni è un
provoca le reazioni
accelera le reazioni chimiche
economy che cos'è
week o nomi è la consapevolezza che se
noi oggi dobbiamo come persone come
imprese come collettività
reinventarci rinnovarci non lo possiamo
fare da soli non possiamo completare
tutte avere le competenze che ci vengano
richieste non possiamo gestire la nostra
singolarità mi è piaciuto molto discorso
di stamattina senza la moltitudine degli
altri quindi collaborare con gli altri
vuol dire saper immaginare in modo
collettivo
io sono anche una designer quindi
concetto di immagine per me è
fondamentale
immaginare un futuro collettivo un po
come il punto di fuga no in una
prospettiva devo avere il mio punto per
mettere in ordine i piani per arrivarci
immaginarci in questa trasformazione per
poter esserci è un cliente presente in
questa stanza va insegnata una grande
lezione che per continuare a durare
bisogna continuare a innovare tutti i
giorni quindi cos'altro mi voglio dire
che collaborare quindi non possiamo
vederlo in modo semplicistico come un
atto di altruismo signori è un atto di
egoismo
che vuol dire che se oggi non collaboro
come persona come impresa e non
costruito reti di imprese non costruisco
una comunità di destino sparisco
quindi week o nomi che cos'è è un
progetto che robotech nostra service
design con i suoi 128 collaboratori più
tutti i 130 autore tutte le persone che
ci mettono il cuore a questo progetto
hanno attivato una piattaforma
collaborativa perché crediamo veramente
che chi divide perde chi condivide vince
anche in affari quindi wii come un
progetto assolutamente
open source copyleft tutto quello che
facciamo viene
condiviso perché crediamo che se
crescete voi cresciamo anche noi e
quindi su cosa sia a questo progetto
si basa sulla volontà di generare
cultura
qualsiasi progetto che noi facciamo non
lo possiamo fare da soli e 130 autori
che hanno partecipato
e centri i progettisti design e filosofi
astronauti scienziati antropologi è
perché ci aiutano a leggere quella
complessità
da più punti di vista ci aiutano a
capire come mettere in crisi parole
scontate come innovazione
ci aiutano riempire di significato i
temi dell'economia a ritrovarci un senso
e quindi i quaderni il libro sono tutte
è un progetto aperto quindi non sapremo
che cosa succederà dopo perché io spero
che molti di voi in questa stanza
sposino e credano insieme a noi
partecipino questo progetto
vuol dire attivare network perché se
allora io per rilanciare la mia impresa
progettare un nuovo prodotto o perché
soltanto ridisegnare il mio profilo
ho bisogno degli altri allora dobbiamo
costruire delle reti tre sante
l'intervento di prima no la complessità
e processi organizzativi la centralità
sarà un nostro co autore futuro sicuro
ma che vuol dire anche impattare sulla
realtà quindi
utilizzare forzare le connessioni fare
in modo di costruire progetti dentro le
imprese che permettano questo di mettere
relazioni le persone per costruire nuovi
conoscenza per fare in modo che le
imprese ritorno in essere in di
consistenti capaci di auto progettare
auto prodursi per poter gestire
l'agilità che un'altra parola che mi è
piaciuta stamattina quindi oggi week o
nomi ha nel suo esperienza di questi
anni 22 progetti
stiamo partecipando ora un progetto che
mi appassiona in modo particolare che ha
un progetto territoriale
dove faremo parte di una cordata per
rilanciare il territorio
quindi uilcom mi vuole essere di fatto
l'occasione per chiederci che oggi il
testo in trasformazione e che abbiamo
visto che sarà ancora più esponenziale
dove c'è chi la fa l'innovazione ma
l'innovazione per portare essere al
porta arrivare alla fine
vuol dire che destra adottata e quindi è
un innovazione di sistema che deve poter
coinvolgere le persone
quindi l'innovazione esponenziale per me
è un atto che non si può gestire in
solitudine
non si può portare avanti da soli si può
solo portare avanti insieme
io vi ringrazio